whether you like it or not in business  how you say something is often at least  as important than what exactly you are  saying and there's specifically One  Voice pattern that actually undermines  your Authority and undermines the  strengths and importance of the  arguments that you are making and this  is called up speak up speak is talking  like this so there's this idea that I  have and this idea is very important so  let me talk to you about it and that's  the first point that I want to make and  the second point so it's always ending  your sentences on a high note a high  pitch this undermines The Authority  instead make sure that when you end it  an argument you actually go down with  the pitch of your voice so you say  something like this today I want to  share this this is the first argument  that I'm making it is really important  to look into this Factor as well this  will let gravitas important and strength  to the points that you're making follow  for more careers content